I love food who here loves food
[Applause]
you know who else loves food Tick Tock
they love food and I love to watch tick
tocks about food so here are three
trending foods from Tick Tock this year
first up we have balsamic cola this
drink went viral when Tick Tock user
Amanda Jones said that her Pilates
instructor drinks it every day as a
sugary soda substitute all you need is a
splash of balsamic vinegar and some
sparkling soda water wow that really
made a different color here
whoa
[Music]
oh okay tastes like soda at first
and then
has sort of like a if vinegar and
Worcestershire sauce had a baby
it's sort of like a cocktail and a steak
dinner all in one sip
I'm into it all right Amanda Jones I see
what you're you've got here and I'm into
it the next up this is custard Toast
French toast using Greek yogurt one egg
cinnamon and Agave
I'm not cutting this very attractively
foreign
oh my God
this is wonderful
oh
sorry
oh my God the Greek yogurt considerably
nice soft pillowy kind of custard like
Center but the bread still totally stays
intact I love this things you learn in
tick tock
of a lot of bread okay finally a
trending holiday treat candy cane
peppermint dip I love a dip this one ooh
has cream cheese that might save it cool
whip and a bunch of crushed up candy
canes I'm gonna dip some graham crackers
in and see what that's all about all
right
not a big peppermint fan it's like you
want to eat your toothpaste as a snack
[Music]
disgusting
that cream cheese doesn't save it at all
okay well if you like toothpaste I
definitely suggest trying this
otherwise skip it all right two out of
three
that's
not
bad
I love favorite trending Tick Tock foods
of 2022 two out of three were definitely
for me try them at home and let us know
what you think collective experience tag
us write us do a tick tock what do you
like about these Trends do you like this
I want to know happy holidays
wow